In Danielle's house, ever since she was a girl, when dinner comes, sometimes they serve a meal that might look familiar to you. Here's the main course. On a big platter, picture drumsticks, white breast meat, golden brown skin.
在丹妮尔家，从她还是个小女孩的时候起，每到晚餐时间，他们有时会端上一道你可能很熟悉的菜。这是主菜。想象一下大盘子里装着鸡腿、白嫩的鸡胸肉，还有金黄色的酥脆鸡皮。
Somebody carves this. Perhaps on a holiday, there's stuffing and cranberry relish on the side. And in Danielle's family, they have a name for this meal. As she told me on the phone recently, the name for this meal is--
有人会把肉切开。或许在节日里，旁边还会配上填料和蔓越莓果酱。在丹妮尔家里，他们对这道菜有一个称呼。正如她最近在电话里告诉我的那样，这道菜的名字是——
Fish.
鱼。
Got that?
听懂了吗？
Fish.
鱼。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it is Your Radio Playhouse, a special program tonight on the wonders of "fish." Actually, we can say the word here. And the word would be "poultry."
那么，这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《你的广播剧场》（Your Radio Playhouse），今晚是一个关于“鱼”之奇迹的特别节目。其实，我们在这里可以说出那个词。那个词应该是“家禽”。
We are in the interregnum of poultry. We stand at this moment between the poultry of Thanksgiving and the poultry of Christmas. This is the peak poultry moment in our American year. Something like a fourth, a little less than a fourth of all the turkey consumed in this country consumed during these few weeks.
我们正处于家禽的间歇期。此时此刻，我们正站在感恩节家禽和圣诞节家禽之间。这是我们美国全年家禽消费的巅峰时刻。这个国家四分之一，或者略少于四分之一的火鸡，都是在这几周内被消耗掉的。
And to honor that, we bring you this evening an odd variety of stories and things you would not hear elsewhere, as we always do of course. Things you not would hear elsewhere-- just transpose the words of that sentence yourselves at home. I'm not going to do that for you-- about turkeys, chickens, ducks, fowl of all kind and their mysterious hold over us.
为了纪念这一点，今晚我们将为您带来一系列奇特的报道和内容，这些内容是你在其他地方听不到的，当然，我们一向如此。在其他地方听不到的内容——你们在家可以自己转换一下那句话的词序。我就不帮你们做了——关于火鸡、鸡、鸭、各种禽类以及它们对我们神秘的吸引力。
Well, I am Ira Glass. A Chicago poet actually named Jim Banks suggested a special name for this special poultry edition of this Your Radio Playhouse. His suggestion, "A Poultry Slam," after, of course, the poetry slams the we hold here in Chicago, in the venerable paneled darkness of the Green Mill Cocktail Lounge each Sunday. Coming up this hour, David Sedaris, Luis Rodriguez, and other writers and radio heroes. And of course, of course, of course, what poultry-positive radio program could be complete without--
嗯，我是艾拉·格拉斯。其实是一位名叫吉姆·班克斯的芝加哥诗人，为这期《你的广播剧场》特别的家禽专刊提议了一个特殊的名字。他的建议是“家禽大满贯”（A Poultry Slam），当然，这是借鉴了我们每周日在芝加哥绿磨坊鸡尾酒吧那古老而阴暗的木镶板厅里举办的诗歌朗诵会（Poetry Slam）。接下来的时间里，大卫·塞达里斯、路易斯·罗德里格斯以及其他作家和广播界的英雄将陆续登场。当然，当然，当然，如果没有……什么样的家禽主题广播节目才算完整呢？
Chickenman!
鸡人！
He's everywhere. He's everywhere!
他无处不在。他无处不在！
Yes, indeed. In the late 1960s, the winged warrior Chickenman struck terror in the hearts of evildoers everywhere, on Chicago radio first and then across the nation. Tonight, we're going to bring you a historic first, the first new episode since 1969, later. That will be later, later.
确实如此。在20世纪60年代末，这位长着翅膀的战士“鸡人”让各地作恶者闻风丧胆，先是在芝加哥广播电台，后来遍及全国。今晚，我们稍后将为你带来一项历史性的首创：自1969年以来的首个新剧集。那是在稍后，稍后。
See, because we're savvy broadcasters here. Even though it's public broadcasting, we're going to make you wait 'til later in the show for that. We know many of you are tuning in for that, and we're going to make you wait.
瞧，因为我们是精明的广播人。尽管这是公共广播，我们还是会让你等到节目后段再听。我们知道你们很多人都是为了这个才收听的，但我们就是要让你等。
OK, to return to our story. Danielle's family. The power of poultry is so great in their lives that when they serve chicken or turkey, they call it--
好了，回到我们的故事。丹妮尔的家人。家禽在他们的生活中有着如此巨大的力量，以至于当他们端上鸡肉或火鸡时，他们称之为——
Fish.
鱼。
That's right. And they call it this for a reason. And the reason has to do with this stuffed hand puppet called Duki.
没错。他们这样称呼是有原因的。而这个原因与这个叫“杜基”的填充玩偶有关。
A little background, Danielle is 28 years old, editor at Details magazine in New York City, a very fashionable magazine. Her sister, Ashley, two years younger, now a graduate student at the University of Michigan. And Duki has been in the family since they were children.
稍微交代一下背景，丹妮尔28岁，是纽约市《Details》杂志的编辑，那是一本非常时尚的杂志。她妹妹阿什莉小她两岁，现在是密歇根大学的研究生。杜基在她们还是孩子时就已经是家里的一员了。
Well, he was a Christmas present when Ashley was about eight and I was about 10. And when he first arrived he was really fluffy. And he was this beautiful, fluffy, white duck. And he had a cape on and black kind of villain/hero goggles. I guess we'd call it hero goggles. And I think he was, because there was an S on his cape, I'm sure he was supposed to be Superduck or something.
嗯，它是阿什莉大约8岁、我大约10岁时收到的圣诞礼物。刚到家时，它非常蓬松。那是一只漂亮、毛茸茸的白鸭子。它披着斗篷，戴着黑色的那种反派或英雄护目镜。我想我们应该叫它英雄护目镜。而且因为斗篷上有个“S”，我肯定它本来应该是“超级鸭”之类的角色。
And he's a puppet. He lost the outfit pretty quickly, and he went naked. And then he became Ashley's vehicle for torturing me.
它是个布偶。衣服很快就弄丢了，它就变得光秃秃的。然后它成了阿什莉折磨我的工具。
Now it is not unusual for older siblings to dominate younger ones. And as children, Danielle pretty much would dominate Ashley. Danielle always got her way, except, except when Duki was around.
年长的孩子主导年幼的兄弟姐妹并不罕见。小时候，丹妮尔几乎总是压制着阿什莉。丹妮尔总是能随心所欲，除非，除非杜基在场。
And basically what would happen is Ashley would channel-- that's kind of an anachronism to use that word in this context-- but Ashley would channel Duki's voice. She would speak as Duki. She would produce the Duki-like voice. And Duki was sarcastic and selfish and bossy. Duki would insult and tease Danielle and give her painful nose squeaks.
基本上发生的情况是，阿什莉会化身——在这种情况下用这个词有点时代错位——但阿什莉会模仿杜基的声音。她会用杜基的语调说话。她会发出那种杜基特有的声音。杜基尖酸刻薄、自私自利又爱发号施令。杜基会侮辱、戏弄丹妮尔，还会捏她的鼻子发出尖叫声。
Whenever Ashley brought Duki into the equation, he was completely the dominant force. I was just putty in Duki's hands.
每当阿什莉把杜基带入局中，它就成了绝对的统治力量。在杜基手里，我简直就是任人摆布的橡皮泥。
Let me ask you to compare his personality with Ashley's personality.
让我请你比较一下它和阿什莉的性格。
Ashley's very considerate. She's very considerate and kind and thoughtful, and very, very sensitive to other people. Very, very concerned about if other people are happy or if someone else doesn't feel good. And Duki has this total "What's for lunch?" attitude, like "What's in it for me?" in your face, totally out for himself, simultaneously a braggart and a total wimp.
阿什莉非常体贴。她非常体贴、善良、周到，对他人也非常非常敏感。总是很担心别人是否快乐，或者别人是否感觉不舒服。而杜基完全是一副“午饭吃什么？”的态度，就像是“我能得到什么好处？”那种咄咄逼人、完全自私自利，同时既爱吹牛又是个十足的胆小鬼。
He's boastful and vain.
它自大又虚荣。
He's just this indomitable spirit. Well, lately, he's at U Mich with my sister. And he tried out for the football team. They've got a good football team there.
它就是那种不屈不挠的精神。嗯，最近它跟我妹妹在密歇根大学。它参加了橄榄球队的选拔。他们那里有支很棒的橄榄球队。
Nationally ranked.
全国排名前列的。
And he said he didn't make it. But he said it was because they thought he'd be more valuable in the band. And they got a good band, too. So apparently, he goes to band practice every day.
它说它没选上。但它说那是因为他们觉得它在乐队里更有价值。他们乐队也很棒。所以很明显，它每天都去参加乐队排练。
And they've got him playing the triangle. He's playing the triangle in the band. And he couldn't come home for Thanksgiving because he had to go be at practice.
他们让它在乐队里敲三角铁。它在乐队里敲三角铁。它感恩节没能回家，因为必须去排练。
18 years after Duki arrived in the Mattoon household, I can say, I think fairly accurately, that the fluffy whiteness is long gone. "Fluffy" is not a word-- you would never use that word with Duki anymore. Nor is two-eyed, actually, if I remember correctly.
在杜基来到马顿家18年后，我想我可以相当准确地说，那曾经蓬松的白色早已不见了。“蓬松”这个词——你再也不会用这个词形容杜基了。事实上，如果我没记错的话，“双眼”这个词也不适用了。
What he looks like, physical-- he's like a slightly pathetic-looking grey, tattered thing.
它的长相，从身体上看——就像个略显可怜、灰扑扑、破破烂烂的东西。
Very tattered.
非常破烂。
Very tattered. But then the fact that his brain, like what's coming out of his mouth, is in complete denial about who he actually is. I don't know. There's just something really, really great about that. And really, you have to love-- you love him for it.
非常破烂。但事实是，它的大脑，也就是它嘴里吐出的那些话，完全否认了它真实的身份。我不知道。这其中真的、真的有一种非常棒的东西。而且你真的必须爱——你是因为这一点才爱它的。
OK, I have been at Danielle's house sometimes and witnessed the following scene. Picture this. Danielle has not spoken with her sister in weeks, picks up the phone, calls her sister Ashley in Michigan. Ashley answers. Danielle asks immediately, "Can you put Duki on the line?" And then Ashley essentially becomes Duki, puts Duki on the line. Danielle talks to Duki for 15, 20 minutes. And then they both hang up. That's the whole conversation. And they both feel satisfied.
好了，我有时会在丹妮尔家亲眼目睹以下场景。想象一下。丹妮尔好几周没和她妹妹说话了，拿起电话打给密歇根的阿什莉。阿什莉接起电话。丹妮尔立刻问：“能让杜基接电话吗？”然后阿什莉本质上就变成了杜基，让杜基接听。丹妮尔和杜基聊上15、20分钟。然后他们都挂断电话。这就是整个谈话过程。他们两个都感到很满足。
I adore Duki. I really love Duki. And sometimes I think if he disappeared, it would really feel like someone died. I mean, I look at him and he looks really old and ratty. And it really makes me sad.
我崇拜杜基。我真的很爱杜基。有时我觉得如果它消失了，真的会感觉像死了什么人一样。我是说，我看着它，它看起来真的很老、很破旧。这真的让我很难过。
Really, I feel like-- it sounds crazy. It really makes me sad to think about a world without Duki, and that it would be a big, empty hole in the world. He takes up as much room in my heart as a lot of people individually. And if something happened to him, if he were lost at an airport or run over by a car, it would really be heartbreaking.
真的，我觉得——这听起来很疯狂。想到一个没有杜基的世界真的让我难过，那会在世界上留下一个巨大的、空洞的缺口。它在我心中的地位和很多独立的人一样重要。如果它发生了什么事，如果在机场丢了或者被车压了，那真的会让人心碎。
So I hope that it's becoming clear why, when you eat dinner in the home of Danielle's family, if they are serving some kind of poultry, chicken or turkey, if you ask anyone in the family what's for dinner, they'll tell you--
所以我希望现在清楚了，为什么当你在丹妮尔家吃晚饭时，如果他们端上某种禽肉，无论是鸡肉还是火鸡，如果你问家里任何人晚饭吃什么，他们都会告诉你——
Fish.
鱼。
Right. And the rationale for that is what?
没错。而这么说的理由是什么？
It freaks Duki out.
这会让杜基抓狂。
It freaks him out, though-- you don't like him to know that perhaps some birds are, in fact, eaten?
虽然这会让它抓狂——你不喜欢让它知道事实上有些鸟确实是被吃掉的？
I think he knows. I think he's in denial about it. He's in denial about most things. He's in denial about the fact that he's totally weak and tiny and dirty. He thinks he's really good-looking and strong, and that he's really smart and has a lot of friends.
我觉得它知道。我觉得它在自欺欺人。它对大多数事情都选择否认。它否认自己其实又弱小、又渺小、又脏兮兮的事实。它认为自己很帅、很强壮，而且很聪明，有很多朋友。
He's in denial about the fact that he's actually stuffed, which he is. Sometimes I tell him that. I say, "Duki, give me a break. You're just stuffed." And he's like, "No way."
它否认自己其实是被填充物塞满的玩具这一事实，而它确实是。有时我告诉它，我说：“杜基，别闹了。你只是个填充玩偶。”它就会说：“才不是。”
Now I thought I would try to book Duki to come on the radio for this show. So a few weeks ago, I contacted Danielle's sister, Ashley. And I asked her if Duki could come on the air.
现在我想尝试预约杜基来参加这个节目。所以几周前，我联系了丹妮尔的妹妹阿什莉。我问她杜基能不能上节目。
And I didn't get a call back. I got an answer back by electronic mail that for Duki to appear, I would have to call someone named Yona Lu, who I could reach through Danielle and Ashley's mom. And when I talked with Danielle, I asked her about this.
我没有收到回电。我收到了一封电子邮件回复，说如果杜基要出现，我必须联系一个叫尤娜·卢的人，我可以联系丹妮尔和阿什莉的母亲找到她。当我和丹妮尔交谈时，我问了她这件事。
I've been informed that the only way that I can reach him is by calling your mom and speaking to Yona Lu? Do I have that name right?
我被告知联系它的唯一方法是打给你们的妈妈并联系尤娜·卢？我名字没记错吧？
Yona Lu, yeah. I think she's acting as his agent.
尤娜·卢，是的。我觉得她在充当它的代理人。
Yona Lu is--
尤娜·卢是——
She's a hedgehog.
它是一只刺猬。
Anything special that I should say to Yona Lu?
我有什么需要对尤娜·卢特别说的吗？
I don't know. She's drives a pretty hard bargain.
我不知道。她可是个很难缠的谈判对手。
Hello?
喂？
Hey, Mrs. Mattoon?
嘿，马顿太太吗？
Yes.
是的。
It's Ira Glass.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Hi, Ira Glass.
你好，艾拉·格拉斯。
Mrs. Mattoon, here's why I called you. I want to do a little story on the radio about Duki.
马顿太太，我打电话给您是因为我想在广播里做一个关于杜基的小专题。
Duki.
杜基。
Duki. And I contacted your daughter, Ashley. And she said that for me to book Duki on to my radio show, I was going to first need to contact Yona Lu.
杜基。我联系了您的女儿阿什莉。她说如果我想预约杜基上我的广播节目，我首先得联系尤娜·卢。
Yeah, you would need to do that.
是的，你需要那样做。
And that I needed to do that through you.
而且我需要通过您来联系。
Yeah.
是的。
Who is Yona Lu?
尤娜·卢是谁？
Yona Lu is-- she's a hedgehog. She's basically taken charge of Duki's financial affairs. And I presume this has something to do with money?
尤娜·卢是——她是一只刺猬。她基本上接管了杜基的财务事务。我想这大概和钱有关？
I don't know, actually. I mean, we--
其实我也不知道。我是说，我们——
That's probably why she said to contact Yona Lu.
那可能就是她让你联系尤娜·卢的原因。
Well, so what do I do now? I was told to contact you if I wanted to get in touch with Yona Lu in order to book Duki. What do I do next?
好吧，那我该怎么办？我被告知如果我想预约杜基，得通过您联系尤娜·卢。接下来我该做什么？
Book Duki, OK. You're going to book Duki.
预约杜基，好的。你要预约杜基。
That's the whole idea. I want to book Duki for the show, for an interview.
就是这个主意。我想预约杜基上节目，做一个采访。
Well, I'll just talk to Yona Lu about it. She says OK, it's OK.
嗯，我会和尤娜·卢谈谈的。她说行就行。
Will Yona Lu want to discuss terms or something?
尤娜·卢会想要讨论条件什么的吗？
She doesn't talk.
她不说话。
So what's going to happen? All right. Should I call you back?
那会发生什么呢？好的。我应该再打给您吗？
You could call me back. Or I'd just go in and check.
你可以打给我。或者我进去确认一下。
You'll just go in and check.
您进去确认一下。
Yeah.
是的。
Should I wait?
我应该等吗？
Yeah.
是的。
All right, I'll wait.
好的，我会等的。
Ira?
艾拉？
Yeah.
是的。
This is just radio?
这只是广播吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Not TV?
不是电视吗？
It's just radio.
只是广播。
And nobody's going to get to be on TV?
而且没人能上电视吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
No, no one's going to be on TV. No, it's strictly radio.
不，没人会上电视。不，这纯粹是广播。
OK, Yona Lu doesn't care what happens then.
好吧，那尤娜·卢（Yona Lu）不在乎会发生什么。
What if it were TV?
如果是电视节目呢？
I think she'd want to be on, too.
我想她也会想上镜的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Radio doesn't do much for her, she doesn't talk.
广播对她来说没什么意义，她又不说话。
OK. In Danielle's family-- I guess you're figuring this out. There's Duki. There's Yona Lu. And then there are four or five other characters, Therese-- I can never keep all their names straight-- who live in this world that's fleshed out with a lot of vivid detail and drama. They have a club called The Smart Set, and people are forever falling in and out of favor with The Smart Set.
好的。在丹妮尔（Danielle）的家庭里——我想你已经搞清楚了。有杜基（Duki）。有尤娜·卢。然后还有其他四五个角色，特蕾丝（Therese）——我永远记不住她们的名字——她们生活在这个充满生动细节和戏剧性的世界里。她们有一个叫“时髦组合”（The Smart Set）的俱乐部，人们总是因为在这个组合里失宠或得宠而分分合合。
Anyway, there are jealousies. There are rivalries. People fight for favors and treats and invitations to ice cream socials. And each of the characters corresponds to some stuffed doll that Danielle and Ashley received as children.
总之，会有嫉妒。会有竞争。人们争夺恩惠、款待和冰淇淋社交聚会的邀请。每个角色都对应着丹妮尔和阿什利（Ashley）小时候收到的某个填充玩偶。
Though a few months ago, Danielle and Ashley were talking. And they realized that one of the characters, Guy Frank, didn't seem to correspond to any particular doll that they could remember. Where did he come from?
虽然几个月前，丹妮尔和阿什利在聊天时意识到，其中一个叫盖伊·弗兰克（Guy Frank）的角色，似乎对应不上她们能想起来的任何玩偶。他是从哪儿来的？
They attempted to recall this. And then one of them did. Guy Frank is Duki's imaginary friend. Duki is such a fully realized imaginary friend that he has his own imaginary friend.
她们试着回忆。然后其中一人想起来了。盖伊·弗兰克是杜基的幻想朋友。杜基这个幻想朋友刻画得太生动了，以至于他还有自己的幻想朋友。
As you might imagine, not everyone in the family takes all this so lightly. Danielle's father, for example, was never too keen on it.
正如你所想，家里并不是每个人都这么轻松地看待这一切。比如丹妮尔的父亲，就一直不太喜欢这样。
He was quite actually bothered by the whole-- he thought we maybe had a problem in the family.
他实际上对整件事感到很困扰——他觉得我们家里可能出了什么问题。
Really?
真的吗？
Mm-hmm. For a while there, we had two daughters that only communicated through a duck.
嗯。有一段时间，我们有两个女儿只通过一只鸭子进行交流。
Yeah. That period that you're describing, when do you mean?
是啊。你描述的那个时期，是指什么时候？
I would say they maybe were 10 and 12 or 9 and 11.
我想她们可能分别是10岁和12岁，或者9岁和11岁。
And they would only communicate through the duck?
她们真的只通过那只鸭子交流吗？
Well, Danielle didn't pay a whole lot of attention to Ashley but she paid quite a lot of attention to the duck. So if Ashley wanted to get Danielle's attention all she had to do was rev up the duck. Danielle thought Duki was very funny, but I can't remember her thinking Ashley was funny.
嗯，丹妮尔不太注意阿什利，但她非常注意那只鸭子。所以如果阿什利想引起丹妮尔的注意，她只需要把鸭子“发动”起来就行了。丹妮尔觉得杜基很有趣，但我记不得她觉得阿什利有趣。
In terms of the relationship between my sister and me, this is probably completely really sick. But I have so much genuine affection and love for Duki that it's very easy to demonstrate those feelings. It's not as easy to demonstrate those feelings toward my sister, just because we never got in the habit of it.
就我和我姐姐的关系而言，这可能真的很病态。但我对杜基怀有非常真挚的喜爱和感情，所以很容易表达出来。要对我的姐姐表达这种感情就不那么容易了，只是因为我们没养成那个习惯。
What percentage of your relationship with your sister is based on your relationship with Duki?
你和你姐姐的关系中，有多大比例是基于你和杜基的关系？
Well, the really fun part of it is based on my relationship with Duki. But I think kind of a big chunk. It definitely gives me this vision into her brain that I wouldn't have otherwise.
嗯，真正有趣的部分是基于我与杜基的关系。但我认为占了很大一部分。这确实让我以一种否则无法拥有的视角窥探她的内心。
Well, I did finally snag an interview with Duki by calling Ashley.
好吧，我最终通过给阿什利打电话，争取到了对杜基的采访。
Is Duki still up for this?
杜基还愿意接受采访吗？
Yeah. He just got back from a party, though.
愿意。不过他刚从一个派对回来。
He just got back from a party?
他刚从派对回来？
Yeah. He was at a happy hour thing with a lot of college students. He's not in college. But he's in the band, so a lot of his friends go to this happy hour on Friday night.
是的。他参加了一个和许多大学生在一起的欢乐时光聚会。他不是大学生。但他加入了乐队，所以他有很多朋友周五晚上会去参加这个欢乐时光。
OK. Well, could you get him?
好吧。那你能不能让他接电话？
Sure. He's upstairs. Just a sec. Here he is.
当然。他在楼上。等一下。他来了。
Hey, Duki?
嘿，杜基？
Yeah? Hey, Ira, how you doing?
嘿？嘿，艾拉（Ira），你好吗？
I'm just fine.
我很好。
Long time no see.
好久不见。
Long time no see, back at you. And welcome to our little radio program.
好久不见。欢迎来到我们的小广播节目。
So what's going on here? You got a whole bunch of celebrities on tonight?
所以这里发生了什么？今晚你请到了一大堆名人吗？
Well, we actually have a number of different people?
嗯，我们确实有几个不同的人？
Real celebs, like, Tom Cruise?
真正的名人，比如汤姆·克鲁斯？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
They're just like Tom Cruise, yes. Yeah. Now, Duki, I was talking to Danielle for our radio program and had her come on and talk about you a little bit. And one of the things that she said was that when she was younger, in order to discipline her, if she was doing something that you didn't like, you could pretty much control her with something called "nose squeaks."
他们就像汤姆·克鲁斯一样，是的。好了，杜基，我为了我们的广播节目和丹妮尔聊过天，让她上节目谈谈你。她说的一件事是，当她还小的时候，为了管教她，如果她做了什么你不喜欢的事，你基本可以通过一种叫“鼻子吱吱声”的东西来控制她。
Yeah. Because she has this kind of-- it's a prominent nose, you know what I mean? It kind of sticks out. And you just want to squeak it. Like over Thanksgiving, we were watching The Muppet Show, and Miss Piggy was on. And she reminded me  a lot of Nielly.
是的。因为她有那种……那是个很显眼的鼻子，你明白我的意思吗？它有点突出来。你只想捏一下。比如感恩节的时候，我们在看《布偶秀》（The Muppet Show），猪小姐（Miss Piggy）也在。她让我想起了尼莉（Nielly）。
Of Danielle.
丹妮尔。
Mm-hmm. Yeah. And Kermit told Miss Piggy, "Move the pork." And so I was telling Nielly to move the pork all week.
嗯。是的。科米蛙（Kermit）对猪小姐说：“把猪肉挪开。”所以整个星期我都在叫尼莉把猪肉挪开。
And would she move?
她会挪吗？
Yes, she would. She would.
是的，她会。她会的。
Now if Ashley would tell her, if Ashley would sit down on the couch and say to Danielle, "Move the pork," what would the effect of that be?
那么如果阿什利叫她，如果阿什利坐在沙发上对丹妮尔说：“把猪肉挪开”，会是什么效果？
You know Nielly. You know how she looks at you when she doesn't approve of something you say or do? She gets this kind of ice-cold stare, and she gives you this side long glance that makes you feel like you're about the size of a pea?
你了解尼莉。你知道当她不赞同你说的话或做的事时，她看你的眼神吗？她会有一种冰冷的凝视，斜眼看着你，让你感觉自己只有豌豆那么大。
Yeah.
是的。
That's what she does. She not as critical of me.
她就是那样做的。她对我没那么刻薄。
Is there anything about the life of a duck that perhaps you could tell our radio audience that we might not know? I'm sure that you know much more about it than we do.
关于鸭子的生活，有什么是你觉得可以告诉我们广播听众，而我们可能不知道的吗？我相信你肯定比我们了解得多。
No, not really. I'm kind of an unusual duck. I'm not really in touch with the whole duck scene, you know?
不，没什么特别的。我是那种不寻常的鸭子。我其实并不怎么接触整个鸭子圈子，你知道吧？
You're not in touch with the whole scene, yeah.
你不怎么接触那个圈子，是吧。
When I had time, I used to migrate once in a while, because I had some friends who are ducks. And I try to keep in touch with them. But lately, I've just started spending more time with people and doing my own thing. And I just don't have time to do those duck things anymore. I just wanted more in my life than that.
以前我有时间的时候，偶尔会迁徙，因为我有一些鸭子朋友。我也尽量和他们保持联系。但最近，我开始花更多时间和人在一起，做我自己的事。我只是没时间再去做那些鸭子的事了。我的生活里想要更多不仅仅是那些东西。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "SATURDAY NIGHT FISH FRY" BY LOUIS JORDAN]
[播放音乐 - 路易斯·乔丹的《周六夜鱼炸饼》]
Well, the story of a 26-year-old graduate student who talks like a duck brings us naturally to the subject of Chickenman. Chickenman first soared the radio airwaves from 1966 to 1969. And nearly every day, there would be a new episode for three years. These are short, little two-minute things, starting on WCFL here in our beloved Chicago.
嗯，一个26岁的研究生像鸭子一样说话的故事，自然地引出了我们关于“鸡侠”（Chickenman）的主题。鸡侠从1966年到1969年首次在广播电台腾飞。三年来，几乎每天都有新的一集。这些都是两分钟的小短剧，最初是在我们心爱的芝加哥WCFL电台播出的。
And after that, Chickenman appeared on over 1,500 radio stations across the country, around the world. According to the people who syndicate it these are the numbers. They say it's been translated into German, Dutch, and Swedish. It is still on the air, they say, in several dozen markets, making it one of the longest-running radio features anywhere.
此后，鸡侠出现在全国乃至世界各地的1500多家广播电台。据发行它的公司统计，这就是数据。他们说它已经被翻译成德语、荷兰语和瑞典语。据说它至今仍在几十个市场播出，使其成为史上最长寿的广播节目之一。
Chickenman began years before National Public Radio existed. It will probably continue years after we are gone. Like the mighty cockroach, like, I don't know, the bagel, like Hamlet, Chickenman endures, will endure.
鸡侠在全国公共广播电台存在之前就开始了。它很可能在我们离开多年后还会继续。就像强大的蟑螂，就像……不知道，就像贝果，就像哈姆雷特，鸡侠永存，并将继续存在。
Coming up later in the show, we'll have the first new Chickenman episode since 1969. Have we mentioned this enough in the show? Should we just mention it every time? Every time we open the mike, I should just mention that? It was written especially for our broadcast by Dick Orkin, the voice of Chickenman. But before we hear that, let's just hear what all the fuss was about.
节目稍后，我们将播出自1969年以来的第一集新版《鸡侠》。我们在节目里提到得够多了吗？我是不是应该每次都提一下？每次我们打开麦克风，我就应该提一下吗？它是为我们的广播特别创作的，作者是迪克·奥金（Dick Orkin），也就是鸡侠的配音。但在听那个之前，让我们先听听大家都在兴奋什么。
Now, another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crimefighter the world has ever known.
现在，全世界有史以来最伟大的打击犯罪英雄生活中的又一个激动人心的篇章。
Bock bock bock bock!
咯咯咯咯！
Chickenman!
鸡侠！
He's everywhere, he's everywhere!
他无处不在，他无处不在！
Benton Harbor, employed as a shoe salesman for a large downtown department store, spends his weekends, his only two days off, striking terror into the hearts of criminals everywhere as the white-winged warrior called Chickenman. How did it come about that Benton Harbor, weekend winged warrior, selected the visage of the chicken in his crusade against the forces of evil? Now it can be told.
本顿·哈伯（Benton Harbor），市中心一家大型百货公司的鞋类推销员，利用他仅有的周末两天假期，化身为名为“鸡侠”的白翼战士，让各地的罪犯心惊胆战。本顿·哈伯这个周末的带翼战士，是如何在打击邪恶势力的斗争中选择鸡的形象的？现在可以揭晓了。
Yes, may I help you?
是的，有什么能帮您的吗？
How do you do? I'm looking for a costume.
你好，我想找一套服装。
Well, what did you have in mind?
嗯，您心里有什么想法吗？
Something that will strike terror into the hearts of criminals everywhere.
某种能让各地罪犯闻风丧胆的服装。
I see. Well, how about this?
我明白了。嗯，这件怎么样？
Hmm. No, I don't think so.
嗯，我觉得不太行。
Why not try it on?
为什么不试试看呢？
Very well.
好吧。
Here, I'll help you.
来，我帮您。
Thank you.
谢谢。
There you are. Now take a look in the mirror.
好了。现在照照镜子看看。
Hmm. Not bad. I wonder if you would permit me to conduct a quick experiment outside this store.
嗯。还不错。不知道您是否允许我在店外进行一个小实验。
Certainly.
当然。
Pardon me, sir.
请原谅，先生。
Yeah?
什么事？
Are you by chance a vicious criminal?
请问你是一个穷凶极恶的罪犯吗？
Uh-huh.
嗯，算是吧。
Fine. Would you take a look at this costume I'm wearing?
好吧。你能看看我身上穿的这套戏服吗？
Yeah.
嗯。
Do you feel anything strange?
你有什么奇怪的感觉吗？
Uh--
呃——
Anything at all?
有什么感觉吗？
Uh, yeah.
呃，有。
And what is that?
那是什么感觉？
I'd like to kiss you.
我想吻你。
Kiss me?
吻我？
Yeah.
对。
How do you account for that?
你怎么解释这种感觉？
Because you look like an adorable bunny rabbit.
因为你看上去就像一只可爱的兔宝宝。
Well, how did it go?
嗯，进行得怎么样了？
What else do you have?
你还有什么别的？
A Teddy bear and a chicken.
一只泰迪熊和一只小鸡。
A Teddy bear?
一只泰迪熊？
It'd be cute.
那会很可爱。
Wrap up the chicken, please.
请把小鸡包起来。
Be listening tomorrow for another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crimefighter the world has ever known.
请明天继续收听世界上最了不起的打击犯罪英雄的另一段激动人心的生活。
Bock bock bock bock!
咯咯咯咯！
Chickenman!
鸡侠！
He's everywhere, he's everywhere!
他无处不在，他无处不在！
The all-new Chickenman, coming up at the end of our show. But next, a real-life story of real poultry and a real poultry farm. Stay with us, won't you?
全新的鸡侠，将在我们节目结束时播出。但接下来，是一个关于真实家禽和真实养鸡场的真实故事。请继续关注我们，好吗？
I'm Julie Showalter. I grew up on a turkey farm in southwest Missouri. "The night 3,000 turkeys died." The day before the night that 3,000 turkeys died, we moved 13,000 turkeys to the range.
我是朱莉·肖沃尔特。我在密苏里州西南部的一个火鸡养殖场长大。“三千只火鸡死掉的那晚”。在那三千只火鸡死掉的那晚的前一天，我们将一万三千只火鸡转移到了放养区。
This requires some explanation. Turkeys spend their first 16 weeks in a heated brooder house. When they are 16 weeks old, they are put outside to range in fenced enclosures.
这需要一些解释。火鸡前16周是在加热的育雏舍中度过的。当它们长到16周大时，它们会被放到户外带围栏的封闭区域放养。
Daddy decided we would herd them to the range. It looked simple enough. We made a temporary chute of wire fencing that ran from the double-end doors of the brooder house 50 yards to the pen. We would get behind the turkeys in the brooder house, shout, wave old shirts and gunny sacks at them, and they would run out the doors, through the chute, into the pen.
爸爸决定让我们把它们赶到放养区。这看起来很简单。我们用铁丝网围成了一条临时的通道，从育雏舍的双开门一直延伸到50码外的围栏里。我们站在育雏舍里的火鸡后面，大喊大叫，挥舞着旧衬衫和麻袋，它们就会从门里跑出来，穿过通道，进入围栏。
And that's the way it worked in the first brooder house. The first turkeys hesitated at the door, walked out cautiously, then moved through the chute and dispersed. The rest followed. It took about an hour. Daddy was pleased. "Let's work straight through," he said. "We'll be done by 10:00."
这就是在第一个育雏舍里的工作方式。第一批火鸡在门口犹豫了一下，小心翼翼地走出来，然后穿过通道散开了。其余的火鸡紧随其后。大约花了一个小时。爸爸很高兴。“我们一鼓作气干完吧，”他说，“10点钟就能完工。”
By the time the turkeys have been in a brooder house for 16 weeks, the air is filled with ammonia, feather particles, and dust. The stench is overwhelming. After an hour in the brooder house, your lungs hurt for a day.
当火鸡在育雏舍待满16周时，空气中就充满了氨气、羽毛微粒和灰尘。那股恶臭令人窒息。在育雏舍待上一个小时，你的肺就会疼上一整天。
You can contract disabling lung diseases from working only a week in a poultry house. Tiny barbed pieces of feather dig into the tissue of your lung and never let go. But we didn't know that then.
在禽舍工作仅仅一周，你就可能染上严重的肺病。细小的带倒钩的羽毛碎片会扎进肺部组织，永远无法排出。但当时我们并不知道这一点。
We moved the temporary fence to the doors of the second brooder house. When we threw open the doors at the end of the second house, it was 9:00 in the morning. The sun streamed in the open doors on turkeys that had never seen direct sunlight.
我们把临时栅栏移到了第二个育雏舍的门前。当我们打开第二个舍房的门时，是上午9点。阳光照进了敞开的门，照在了那些从未见过直射阳光的火鸡身上。
The one thing you can count on with turkeys is that you never know how they are going to react. I've seen turkeys clamber against a fence trying to get into a range fire. I've seen them rush toward a screaming child, trying to kill it. And I've seen them run from a screaming child, spooked and terrified.
关于火鸡，你唯一能确定的是你永远不知道它们会作何反应。我见过火鸡挤在栅栏上试图冲进放养区的火火里。我见过它们冲向尖叫的孩子，试图杀死它。我也见过它们被尖叫的孩子吓得四散奔逃，惊恐万状。
These turkeys didn't want to go into the sun. As we pushed from behind, they compacted. It was like an old adventure movie where the walls are closing in. But there was no wall at the end, only a patch of sunlight which turkeys would not touch.
这些火鸡不想进入阳光下。当我们从后面推它们时，它们挤在了一起。就像那种墙壁正在闭合的旧冒险电影一样。但尽头没有墙，只有一片火鸡绝不肯踏入的阳光区域。
We yelled louder, waved our cloths, kicked at the ones in the rear. Finally, Daddy walked through the solid carpet of turkeys to break the logjam at the front. He stood at the edge of the sunlight, lifting the turkeys three or four at a time with his feet, stirring them with this legs, forcing them into the sun.
我们大声呼喊，挥动手中的布料，踢着后面的火鸡。最后，爸爸穿过那片厚实的火鸡群，试图打破前面的拥堵。他站在阳光的边缘，用脚一次次把三四只火鸡拨开，用腿搅动它们，强迫它们进入阳光下。
Suddenly, they broke free. As stubbornly as they had refused to go into the light, they now rushed toward it. They ran in a panic, piling on top of each other, knocking down the temporary fence. By the time Daddy could get the doors closed, at least 1,000 turkeys had escaped and were running free on the farm, onto our neighbor's farm, into the road.
突然，它们冲破了阻碍。它们刚才有多固执地拒绝进入光亮处，现在就有多狂乱地冲向那里。它们惊慌失措地奔跑，堆叠在一起，撞倒了临时栅栏。等爸爸赶去把门关上时，至少有1000只火鸡逃了出去，在农场里、邻居的农场里以及公路上四处乱跑。
We didn't own the turkeys. We raised them for a company that owned the hatchery, the feed mill, the fleet of trucks that delivered and loaded the turkeys, the processing plant. We got a portion of the profits, if there were profits.
这些火鸡不属于我们。我们是为一家公司代养的，这家公司拥有孵化场、饲料厂、运送和装载火鸡的卡车队，以及加工厂。我们只能分到一部分利润，前提是必须有利润。
With 1,000 turkeys gone, there would be no profits on this flock. 16 weeks of Daddy working 14-hour days, of my sisters and me working alongside him any time we weren't in school, all for no pay. And if we weren't paid for this flock, we would have no cash coming in until the next flock was raised.
丢了1000只火鸡，这批火鸡就不会有利润了。爸爸16周以来每天工作14个小时，我和姐妹们只要不在上学就跟他一起干，所有这些都是白干。如果我们这批火鸡拿不到报酬，在下一批火鸡养大之前，我们将没有任何现金收入。
It took us eight hours to round up the escaped turkeys, four of us trying to track down 1,000 birds that had the whole world in which to hide and run from us. The sun beat down, and the air was thick and humid. We stopped once for water, and my sister, Billie, the youngest of us, just 11, vomited from the cold water hitting her stomach after hours of sun, heat, and dehydration.
我们花了八个小时才找回那些逃跑的火鸡，我们四个人试图追踪1000只鸟，而它们有整个世界可以用来躲藏和奔跑。烈日当空，空气又厚又湿。我们停下来喝了一次水，我最小的妹妹比莉，才11岁，因为在阳光、高温和脱水下待了几个小时后喝了冷水，竟然呕吐了。
As she lay on the ground, shaking and holding her stomach, I hated her for being the one too sick to continue. But even she was not too sick. We all went on. She got an extra five minutes to rest, but we all went on.
当她躺在地上，颤抖着捂住肚子时，我恨她因为生病而无法继续。但即使是她，也没有病到无法坚持的地步。我们都继续前行。她多休息了五分钟，但我们所有人都坚持了下来。
You may be asking right now how my father could be so cruel, how he could work young girls like that? Or you may think that I'm exaggerating, that self-pity has magnified our distress. I tell you, this is no exaggeration. And I tell you, my father had no choice. Or that any choice he had was so far in the past that there was no unraveling it. Years later, when we were grown, we caught a glimpse of his guilt, his bitterness over what he had done to us. "I couldn't afford n------," he told my sister Billie. "So I had daughters."
你现在可能在问，我父亲怎么能如此残忍，他怎么能让年幼的女儿干那种活？或者你可能认为我在夸大其词，认为自怜放大了我们的痛苦。我告诉你，这绝无夸大。而且我告诉你，我父亲别无选择。或者说，他所做的任何选择都已经是在太遥远的过去，已经无法挽回了。多年后，当我们长大成人，我们窥见了他心中的内疚，他对强加给我们的一切所感到的痛苦。“我雇不起黑人劳工，”他对比莉妹妹说，“所以我只能生女儿。”
At 6 o'clock, we rebuilt the chute. We opened the doors, and the 6,000 remaining turkeys, the sun now low in the sky behind them, walked through to the pen. We cleaned up. We ate supper. And we went to bed. That's the day we had before the night 3,000 turkeys died.
6点钟，我们重建了通道。我们打开门，剩下的6000只火鸡，在落日的余晖中，走进了围栏。我们打扫了现场。吃了晚饭。然后上床睡觉。这就是在那三千只火鸡死掉的那晚之前我们所经历的一天。
At midnight, Mother woke us up. "We have to get to the pen. Daddy needs us." We had been too exhausted to hear the storm. We ran out in the driving rain. Flashes of lightning showed Daddy picking up turkeys and throwing them, one after the other.
午夜时分，妈妈叫醒了我们。“我们得去围栏那边。爸爸需要我们。”我们太累了，没能听到暴风雨的声音。我们冒着倾盆大雨跑了出去。闪电照亮了正在抓起火鸡并把它们一只接一只扔开的爸爸。
When people learn I grew up on a turkey farm, they invariably ask, "Is it true? Are they really so stupid that they open their mouths in the rain, look up at the sky, and drown?" The answer is yes, some of them do that. They are that stupid. But that's not how 3,000 die in one night.
当人们知道我在火鸡养殖场长大时，他们总是会问：“是真的吗？它们真的笨到会在雨中张开嘴，仰望天空，然后淹死吗？”答案是肯定的，有些确实会那样。它们就是那么笨。但这就是为什么一晚会死掉3000只的原因。
They die because they are scared, and they huddle together in their fear. They climb on top of each other, trying to get close, to find protection in the mass of bodies. And they suffocate.
它们死是因为它们害怕，在恐惧中它们挤在一起。它们爬到彼此身上，试图靠近，试图在肉堆中寻求保护。然后它们窒息了。
We called it piling. It wasn't unusual for a loud noise to cause a pile in the brooder house. If there wasn't someone to pull them off each other, 50 could die because someone slammed a door.
我们称之为“堆叠”。噪音导致育雏舍里的火鸡堆叠起来并不罕见。如果没有人把它们扒开，50只火鸡可能会因为有人猛关一扇门而死掉。
But this was worse than any pile we'd seen, turkeys who'd never spent a night outdoors panicked by thunder, lightning, and rain in sheets. All we could do is pull them out of the pile and throw them away from it. They would run back, still seeking the comfort of the group.
但这比我们见过的任何堆叠都更严重，那些从未在户外过夜的火鸡被雷声、闪电和倾盆大雨吓坏了。我们唯一能做的就是把它们从堆里拉出来，扔到远处。它们又会跑回来，依然寻找群体带来的安慰。
After a while standing in mud, grabbing soaked turkeys, throwing them, grabbing more, you don't know if the ones you are throwing are dead or alive. You don't care. Maybe we saved some.
在泥泞中站了一会儿，抓起被淋透的火鸡，扔掉，再抓更多，你已经分不清你扔的是死的还是活的了。你根本不在乎。也许我们救下了一些。
The next day, the sky was cloudless, and the sun bore down on us again. We picked up dead turkeys, throwing them onto the back of a flatbed truck. Daddy drove the truck into a field far from the house. He poured gasoline on them and struck a match. They burned for days.
第二天，天空万里无云，太阳再次炙烤着我们。我们捡起死去的火鸡，扔到平板卡车的车厢后。爸爸把卡车开到远离房子的田野里。他往上面倒了汽油，划了一根火柴。它们燃烧了几天几夜。
Well, Julie Showalter lives in Burr Ridge, Illinois, and says that she still does eat turkey. Well, twice a year, she eats it. And this is the special Poultry Slam edition of Your Radio Playhouse, coming to you from WBEZ in Chicago. Stay with us, won't you?
朱莉·肖沃尔特现在住在伊利诺伊州的伯尔里奇，她说她仍然吃火鸡。嗯，一年吃两次。这就是《你的广播剧场》特别的“家禽大满贯”版本，从芝加哥的WBEZ为您播出。请继续关注我们，好吗？
This is Luis Rodriguez. And I'm going to read my poem, "The Rooster Who Thought it Was a Dog." Echo Park mornings came on the wings of a rooster's gnawing squawk. This noise, unfortunately, also brought in the afternoon, evenings, and most hours of the day. The rooster had no sense of time, nor any desire to commit to one. He'd cock-a-doodle whenever he had the notion.
我是路易斯·罗德里格斯。我将朗读我的诗《那只自以为是狗的公鸡》。回声公园的早晨是在公鸡刺耳的叫声中降临的。不幸的是，这种噪音也把下午、晚上以及一天中的大部分时间都搅乱了。这只公鸡没有时间观念，也不想遵守任何时间。它只要有兴致就会喔喔叫。
For late sleepers, day sleepers, or your plain, ordinary, run of the mill night sleepers, annoyance had this rooster's beak. It was enough to drive one crazy. Often, I open my back window that faced the alley just across from the backyard where the rooster made his home. "Shut up, or I'll blow your stinking brains out," I'd yell. Great communication technique.
对于那些起得晚的人、白天睡觉的人，或者普通的夜猫子来说，这只公鸡的喙简直是烦人的源头。这足以让人发疯。我经常打开面对小巷的后窗，而那小巷对面就是公鸡安家的后院。“闭嘴，不然我就打爆你的臭脑袋，”我会大喊。多好的沟通技巧。
It worked on the brats next door, but the rooster never flinched. With calm aplomb, it continued to squawk. For one thing, the rooster never gave out a bona fide cock-a-doodle. It sort of shouted it out.
这招对隔壁的熊孩子管用，但那只公鸡却从未退缩。它依然泰然自若地继续啼叫。首先，那只公鸡从来没发出过正宗的喔喔声。它更像是喊出来的。
It happened that the rooster lived with three dogs, a German Shepherd and two mutts. The dogs barked through their existence. They barked at everything in sight. I finally concluded that rooster thought it was a dog. Somehow, I didn't mind the dogs barking. But when a rooster barks, that's murder.
碰巧这只公鸡和三条狗住在一起，一条德国牧羊犬和两只杂种狗。这些狗的一生都在叫。它们对着视野里的一切东西叫。我最后得出结论，那只公鸡以为自己是条狗。不知怎么的，我不介意狗叫。但当一只公鸡叫的时候，那简直是谋杀。
In fact, I often saw it running alongside the dogs as they raced across the dirt yard, barking at passing cars or people. If the dogs went left, the rooster went left. They'd go right, and dang if that rooster didn't go right as well. Now I don't know if this is a regular condition for roosters.
事实上，我经常看到它和狗一起跑，当它们穿过土院子，对着经过的汽车或行人狂吠时。如果狗向左跑，公鸡也向左跑。它们向右跑，该死的，那只公鸡也会向右跑。现在我不知道这对于公鸡来说是不是一种正常状态。
I thought I had a story for the Weekly World News. I could see it now. "The Rooster Who Thinks it's a Dog." Who knows what rooster dementia we had here? And whether the rooster chased cats up trees or pissed on fire hydrants, this wasn't clear.
我以为我能给《世界新闻周刊》提供一个故事。我已经能想象到了。“那只自以为是狗的公鸡”。谁知道我们这里出了什么公鸡痴呆症？至于这只公鸡是会追着猫爬树，还是会在消防栓上撒尿，这就不得而知了。
But once I grasped the heart of the matter, I began to see the rooster in another light. I felt sorry for this fowl with an identity problem. And I wondered how it must react when its owners threw chicken bones to the dogs. Would it nibble on the remains of its favorite hen? I shuddered at the thought.
但一旦我掌握了事情的真相，我开始以另一种眼光看待这只公鸡。我为这只患有身份认同障碍的禽类感到难过。我心想，当主人把鸡骨头扔给狗时，它会作何反应？它会啃食它最喜欢的母鸡的残骸吗？一想到这我不禁打了个寒颤。
Yet despite the revelation of the rooster's bark, the problem of sleep didn't end. Then one day, a new neighbor, a young lady, who often drank herself to bliss, got a gun and blew the rooster away. She became somewhat of a local hero.
然而，尽管揭开了公鸡叫声的谜底，睡眠问题依然没有解决。后来有一天，一位经常喝得酩酊大醉的新邻居，一位年轻女士，拿了一把枪，把那只公鸡轰飞了。她成了某种当地英雄。
I must say, though, it was an unfitting end for the bird. But I suppose one can tolerate barking dogs. But barking roosters? That's another matter altogether.
我必须说，这对那只鸟来说是个不合适的结局。但我认为人们可以容忍吠叫的狗。但吠叫的公鸡？那是完全另一回事了。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "A CHICKEN AIN'T NOTHIN' BUT A BIRD" BY CAB CALLOWAY]
[音乐播放 - 卡布·卡洛威演唱的《小鸡不过是只鸟》]
Now, another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crimefighter the world has ever known.
现在，世界上最了不起的打击犯罪英雄的生活中的另一段激动人心的插曲。
Bock bock bock bock!
咯咯咯咯！
Chickenman!
鸡侠！
He's everywhere, he's everywhere!
他无处不在，他无处不在！
The office of the Police Commissioner of Midland City.
米德兰市警察局长的办公室。
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
[电话铃响]
Hello, this is the commissioner--
喂，我是局长——
Miss Helfinger, this is the winged warrior.
赫尔芬格小姐，我是飞翔的勇士。
Yes, what is it?
是的，什么事？
Please inform the commissioner that I'm now all set for test sequence number one.
请通知局长，我已经为测试序列一号做好了准备。
What?
什么？
It's all primed and ready to go.
一切准备就绪，随时可以开始。
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
The chicken missile, Miss Helfinger.
小鸡导弹，赫尔芬格小姐。
The chicken missile?
小鸡导弹？
Yes. So tell the commissioner I'm ready for test sequence number one.
是的。所以告诉局长我已为测试序列一号准备就绪。
[INTERCOM BUZZING]
[对讲机蜂鸣声]
Yes, Miss Helfinger?
好的，海尔芬格小姐？
Commissioner, the chicken missile is ready to go.
局长，小鸡导弹准备就绪了。
Huh?
啊？
The chicken missile.
小鸡导弹。
Oh, yes, of course. The--
噢，对，没错。那……
And it's ready for test sequence number one.
它已经准备好进行一号测试程序了。
Test sequence number one.
一号测试程序。
Number one.
一号。
Well, that's very nice, very nice, yes.
嗯，那很好，非常好，是的。
Hello, winged warrior.
你好，长翅膀的战士。
Right here, Miss Helfinger.
就在这儿，海尔芬格小姐。
The commissioner said that's very nice.
局长说那很好。
Oh, fine. In that case, Miss Helfinger, have the commissioner stand by with the chicken missile receiver.
噢，太好了。既然这样，海尔芬格小姐，让局长准备好小鸡导弹接收器。
What?
什么？
I'm going to count down--
我要开始倒数了——
Listen.
听着。
[INAUDIBLE]. We'll see you at 1400 hours.
[听不清]。我们14:00见。
[TELEPHONE HANGING UP]
[电话挂断声]
Hello, wait--
喂，等等——
[INTERCOM BUZZING]
[对讲机嗡嗡声]
Yes, Miss Helfinger?
好的，海尔芬格小姐？
Commissioner?
局长？
Yes.
在。
If I would say to you, "Prepare the chicken missile receiver," would you know--
如果我对你说，“准备好小鸡导弹接收器”，你会知道——
No, I wouldn't.
不，我不知道。
I didn't think you would. Commissioner?
我就知道你不知道。局长？
Yes.
在。
I would suggest that you crouch under your desk.
我建议你蹲到桌子底下。
Crouch under my desk?
蹲到桌子底下？
Yes, it should provide some protection.
是的，那应该能提供一些保护。
From--
避开——
[CRASHING NOISES]
[撞击声]
[COUGHING]
[咳嗽声]
What?
什么？
From the chicken missile.
避开小鸡导弹。
Oh.
噢。
Wow. Say, that chicken missile really works nifty. Will the Midland City Fire Department recommend that a chicken missile receiver be installed in what's left of Midland City Hall? Be listening tomorrow for another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crimefighter the world has ever known.
哇。说真的，那枚小鸡导弹真是好用。米德兰市消防局会建议在米德兰市政厅的残骸中安装小鸡导弹接收器吗？请明天继续收听这个世界上最伟大的犯罪斗士生活的又一激动人心的片段。
Bock bock bock bock!
咯咯哒，咯咯哒！
Chickenman!
小鸡侠！
He's everywhere, he's everywhere!
他无处不在，他无处不在！
More Chickenman. That all-new episode, coming up.
更多小鸡侠的故事，全新一集，马上就来。
In the meantime, my friend Verta tells this story. Verta, Vertamae Grosvenor, is a National Public Radio commentator, host of an NPR show called Seasonings. Anyway, back in 1970, she published a cookbook. And she was interviewed about it on television by Barbara Walters.
与此同时，我的朋友维塔讲了这样一个故事。维塔，也就是维塔梅·格罗夫纳，是国家公共电台的评论员，也是NPR节目《调味品》的主持人。总之，回到1970年，她出版了一本食谱。芭芭拉·沃尔特斯曾在电视上采访过她。
And as Verta tells this story, OK, she's on TV, making fried chicken for Barbara Walters. And at some point, Barbara Walters asks her, "How do you tell the chicken's done?"
正如维塔所讲，当时她在电视上为芭芭拉·沃尔特斯炸鸡。在某个时刻，芭芭拉·沃尔特斯问她：“你怎么知道鸡肉熟了？”
And Verta tells her, "You can tell by the sound." Ms. Walters gives her this look which says, basically, "Give me a break," and quickly cuts to a commercial. And Verta says that's always people's reaction.
维塔告诉她：“听声音就能听出来。”沃尔特斯女士给了她一个眼神，意思基本上是“别开玩笑了”，然后迅速切入了广告。维塔说人们总是这种反应。
They say, "You're crazy, Verta. That's not it." They say, "Tell me something real. What is it? 15 minutes? 20 minutes," or whatever. And I say, "You've got to listen to the sound of the grease. Listen to the music."
他们说：“你疯了，维塔。根本不是那样。”他们说：“告诉我点靠谱的。是多少？15分钟？20分钟，还是别的什么。”而我说：“你得听油脂发出的声音。听那音乐。”
So you have been claiming for years that you can tell if the chicken's done purely by the sound. And so to determine if that's true, we've decided to conduct a little radio experiment here, with your permission. The other night, we fried a chicken, and we recorded it at different stages of its frying. And we are going to play you now four different moments in the frying of the chicken that we've changed the order of.
所以你多年来一直声称仅凭声音就能判断鸡肉是否熟了。为了确定这一点是否属实，经你同意，我们决定在这里做一个小小的广播实验。前几天晚上，我们炸了一只鸡，并录下了它在不同炸制阶段的声音。现在我们将为你播放四段鸡肉炸制过程中的声音片段，顺序已被我们打乱了。
I'm sure you did, Ira.
我相信你们这么做了，艾拉。
Well, I'm telling you up front. And we want you to listen to the four of them and identify which one is the one where the chicken is done. In other words, can you tell that the chicken is done without any visual cues, without the help of smelling what the chicken is smelling like? Can it be done purely, purely on the basis of sound?
嗯，我提前告诉你。我们希望你听这四个片段，并找出哪一段是鸡肉熟了的时候。换句话说，在没有任何视觉线索，也不借助嗅觉的情况下，你能听出鸡肉熟了吗？单凭声音真的能做到吗？
Let's roll. And our listeners at home can play along with us here. Let's roll the first little sample sound.
开始吧。我们在家的听众也可以和我们一起猜。播放第一个声音片段。
[CHICKEN FRYING]
[炸鸡声]
I would say--
我会说——
Yeah?
嗯？
I'd say that's something like the middle.
我会说那大概是中间阶段。
OK. But that definitely isn't towards the end, you're saying.
好的。但你认为那肯定不是快熟的时候，对吧。
Yeah, it's in the middle going toward the end. It's in the three fourths part.
是的，是在往后走的中段。是四分之三的部分。
OK, let's hear sound number two, please.
好的，请听第二个声音。
[CHICKEN FRYING]
[炸鸡声]
Number two is toward the end, too.
第二个也是接近尾声的时候。
OK. Number three.
好的。第三个。
[CHICKEN FRYING]
[炸鸡声]
I think that's the beginning, more toward the beginning.
我觉得那是刚开始，更偏向开始的时候。
That is more toward the beginning. And number four.
那确实更偏向开始。接下来是第四个。
[CHICKEN FRYING]
[炸鸡声]
That's an ender. It's toward the end.
那是终结者。它接近尾声。
OK.
好的。
When all those little balls are forming on the bottom, those little, nice, crusty.
当锅底形成那些小球的时候，那些又脆又好的小东西。
Now, Verda, if you would have to hazard a guess as to which one would be the very last one--
现在，维塔，如果你必须猜测哪一个是最后阶段的话——
I still say it's one or two that's toward the end.
我仍然说是第一个或第二个接近尾声。
And the answer is number two, which means that using only the sound of the chicken, Ms. Vertamae Grosvenor can get close to telling when chicken is done, but can't be totally sure of it. In short, this was hard.
答案是第二个，这意味着仅靠鸡肉的声音，维塔梅·格罗夫纳女士可以接近判断出鸡肉何时炸好，但不能完全确定。简而言之，这很难。
Yes, it was hard. You have to see it. Do you know what I mean?
是的，确实很难。你必须亲眼看着它。你明白我的意思吗？
Yeah.
明白。
Oh, it's a serious, labor-intensive thing. You've got to stay on it. You just can't be talking on the phone and watching TV. You've got to stay on that chicken.
噢，这是一项严肃且耗费体力的事情。你必须一直盯着它。你不能一边打电话一边看电视。你必须守着那只鸡。
I was asking your daughters today, and they were saying how they can also tell if rice is done by the sound.
我今天问了你的女儿们，她们说她们也能听出米饭是否煮好了。
Oh yeah, that's true. Yeah, I taught them that. Those are the kind of family values I taught my children. "Listen to the sound of the chicken."
噢，是的，那是真的。我教过她们。那就是我教给我孩子们的家庭价值观。“听鸡肉的声音。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
"Listen to the sound of the rice." You talked to both of them?
“听米饭的声音。”你和她们两个都聊过了？
I talked to both of them. They were both really funny. One of them said, "Everything that she cooks is golden brown and perfect, perfect, perfect."
我和她们两个都聊了。她们都非常有趣。其中一个说：“她做的所有东西都是金黄酥脆，完美，完美，完美。”
Who said that?
是谁说的？
I believe it was Chandra.
我想是钱德拉。
Really?
真的吗？
But she said, "But just because we're her daughters, that doesn't mean that she tells us the real recipes. We ask her for the recipes, and tells us recipes. But then when we cook them, they're not the same. And we know that she's holding back on ingredients.
但她说：“仅仅因为我们是她的女儿，并不意味着她会告诉我们真正的秘方。我们向她要秘方，她也确实给了。但当我们照着做时，味道却完全不对。我们知道她肯定在配料上有所保留。”
That's-- well, that's not quite true, but you know.
那……嗯，那不完全是真的，但你知道的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That is true. You don't tell them all the ingredients.
那是真的。你确实没有把所有配料都告诉她们。
Well, no. I just tell them, but then they have to find out the rest for themselves.
嗯，没有。我只是告诉了她们，但剩下的她们得自己去发现。
There you go.
就是这样。
You see what I'm saying?
你明白我的意思了吗？
As with so many things in parenting.
正如为人父母的许多事情一样。
I say, "I put a little ginger in." Then they have to figure out how much a little ginger is. That's what they have to do.
我说：“我放了一点姜。”然后她们必须弄清楚“一点姜”到底是多少。这就是她们要做的事。
I tell you, going into this, I was completely convinced that you were just going to snap and get it, and it was going to be really easy. But it turned out to be hard without those other cues. And I guess I've learned that the chicken is a tricky thing. Chicken is tricky. Chicken is craftier than we usually give it credit for.
跟你说实话，一开始，我完全确信你肯定能立刻掌握并做出来，而且会非常容易。但事实证明，如果没有那些额外的提示，这真的很难。我想我已经明白，处理鸡肉是一件棘手的事。鸡肉很难弄。鸡肉比我们通常认为的要狡猾得多。
Oh, but did I tell you this one? I have something to tell you about chickens.
噢，但我跟你说过这个吗？关于鸡，我有些事情要告诉你。
All right, yeah.
好的，请说。
The chicken and the rooster had a fight. The chicken knocked the rooster out of sight. Rooster told the chicken, "That's alright. Meet you in the gumbo tomorrow night."
鸡和公鸡打了一架，鸡把公鸡打得不见踪影。公鸡对鸡说：“没关系，明晚在秋葵浓汤里见。”
Well, the fabulous Vertamae Grosvenor from a studio in Washington, DC. More fun a-comin', writer David Sedaris in New York City. And of course, have we mentioned-- I can't remember. Did we mention the new Chickenman episode, the first one since 1969? Did we mention it? All right. Stay with us.
好的，这是来自华盛顿特区演播室的精彩人物维塔梅·格罗夫纳。接下来还有更多精彩内容，作家大卫·塞达里斯将从纽约市连线。当然，我们提到了吗——我不记得了。我们提到了新的《鸡侠》剧集吗？这是自1969年以来的第一集。我们提到了吗？好的，请继续收听。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "EAT THAT CHICKEN" BY CHARLES MINGUS]
[音乐播放 - 查尔斯·明格斯的《吃那只鸡》]
July 19, 1992. This afternoon, at the 26th Street Flea Market, I had one of those experiences that remind me why I shop in the first place. Not shop like grocery shop, but step out into the world searching for that one thing I cannot name.
1992年7月19日。今天下午，在第26街跳蚤市场，我经历了一件让我回想起当初为什么要购物的事。不是那种去杂货店的购物，而是走进这个世界，去寻找那种我说不出名字的东西。
I pass the usual objects, the grinning mammies offering themselves up as salt and pepper shakers, the coffee table made from dice, another head carved from a coconut. "That's collectible," the dealers say, referring to an ashtray in the shape of a doll-sized toilet bowl. Collectible to who?
我经过那些寻常的物品：咧着嘴笑的黑人保姆玩偶，把自己当作盐和胡椒瓶；用骰子做成的咖啡桌；另一个用椰子雕刻的人头。“那是收藏品，”摊主指着一个玩偶大小的马桶形状的烟灰缸说。谁会收藏这个？
Last weekend at the flea market, I saw this thing, a taxidermied turkey's head attached to its own foot. This turkey was equipped with that length of flesh that spills from the top of its beak and fell to its neck. Stiff red hair stood out from the head and shoulders, and the claws were really sharp. You'd think that something armed like that might be able to protect itself.
上周末在跳蚤市场，我看到了这个东西：一个连接在自己脚上的动物标本火鸡头。这只火鸡身上装有那种从喙部上方一直垂到脖子的肉质长条。僵硬的红色毛发从头和肩膀上竖起，爪子非常锋利。你会觉得拥有这种武装的东西应该能保护自己。
I pictured its maker standing by a chopping block saying, "I know. I'll take the turkey's head and attach it to the foot." Why would you do that? Or more importantly, what sort of life would you lead that might enable you to make this connection?
我脑海中浮现出它的制造者站在砧板旁说：“我知道了，我要把火鸡的头砍下来装在它的脚上。”你为什么要做这种事？或者更重要的是，过什么样的生活才让你做出这种连接？
I was hypnotized by this object and asked the price as if I were under a spell. "$45," the dealer said. My tongue was dry from hanging in the open air, and I tried to fit it back into my mouth. "All right," she said, "$35. $30." But she could have gone up. "All right. $85. $120. $370."
我被这个物体迷住了，就像被施了咒语一样问了价格。“45美元，”摊主说。我的舌头因为一直在空气中晾着而变得干涩，我试图把它缩回嘴里。“好吧，”她说，“35美元，30美元。”但她本可以要价更高的，“好吧，85美元，120美元，370美元。”
I had no choice but to follow wherever she led me. I handed over my wallet in a trance, just gave it to her, thinking she could take the whole thing, the cash, blank checks, library card, whatever. Take it all.
我别无选择，只能跟着她指引的任何方向走。我像陷入了恍惚状态一样交出了钱包，直接给了她，心想她可以拿走所有东西：现金、空白支票、借书证，随便什么。全拿走吧。
I stared into the face of this taxidermied turkey's head, and nothing else mattered. Tomorrow, what's that? Yesterday doesn't count. My life began the moment I could call this thing my own.
我盯着这个火鸡头标本的脸，其他的一切都不重要了。明天？那是什么？昨天不作数。我的生活从我能称这个东西为我的那一刻开始。
On the way home I felt giddy and confident that I could approach anyone at all and say, "I'll give you one hundred-- no, $500,000 if you can guess what I've got in this paper sack." And I swear that not one of them could have come up with the right answer. I walked home 30 blocks, looking everyone square in the eye and thinking, "Sucker."
回家的路上，我感到眩晕，并自信地认为我可以接近任何一个人说：“如果你能猜出我这个纸袋里装的是什么，我就给你一百……不，50万美元。”我发誓，他们中没有一个人能给出正确答案。我走了30个街区回家，直视着每个人的眼睛，心想：“笨蛋。”
Well, David Sedaris is the author of Barrel Fever, often heard on NPR's Morning Edition.
大卫·塞达里斯是《桶中狂热》的作者，经常在NPR的《早间版》节目中出现。
All right. Well, forget about those two new Beatles songs, so-called Beatles songs, put out two and a half decades after the group broke up, because here, here, right here on Your Radio Playhouse , we have chicken mania. Chickenman -ia All right, forget that.
好的。好吧，忘了那两首披头士的新歌——所谓的披头士歌曲，在乐队解散二十五年后才发布——因为在这里，就在这里，在《你的广播剧场》，我们有“鸡侠狂热”。鸡侠狂热……好吧，忘了这个。
Dick Orkin, the voice of Chickenman and the brains behind Chickenman. This is the style that launched 1,000 imitators. When I was a kid listening to the radio in Baltimore, I heard this stuff, and really, Chickenman , until the time I was 13 years old, and The Tooth Fairy , another series that Dick Orkin did. And then occasionally, you would hear these commercials for Time magazine or other stuff.
迪克·奥金，《鸡侠》的声音，也是《鸡侠》背后的策划者。这就是那种开启了千位模仿者的风格。我还是个孩子在巴尔的摩听广播时，就听过这些。在我13岁之前，《鸡侠》还有迪克·奥金制作的另一个系列《牙仙子》真的很有影响力。偶尔，你还会听到这些为《时代》周刊或其他产品做的广告。
You could always tell. You could always tell. That's the guy. That's the guy. Those are [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
你总是能听出来。你总是能听出来。就是那家伙。就是那家伙。那些都是……[听不清]。
Because they all had this very deadpan feeling. There was just something offbeat. You couldn't even quite put your finger on what it was. And I, like many people who got into radio in the years that followed, spent the early part of my career in radio trying to imitate that sound and then giving up because of the utter futility of that.
因为它们都有那种非常冷静平淡的感觉。就是有一种反传统的特质。你甚至说不出那究竟是什么。像许多后来投身广播界的人一样，我职业生涯的早期也是试图模仿那种声音，然后因为彻底的徒劳而放弃了。
And so we are very, very pleased. All of that is a way of saying we are very, very pleased. We, the corporate we, I and the little production staff here at Your Radio Playhouse, we are very pleased to be able to bring the first new Chickenman episode written since 1969, the first full episode written since 1969. You know, Chickenman is getting up in years. And no one appears to be more aware of that than his creator.
所以我们非常、非常高兴。说了这么多，就是为了表达我们非常、非常高兴。我们，企业化的“我们”，我和《你的广播剧场》的小制作团队，我们非常高兴能带来自1969年以来撰写的第一集新的《鸡侠》，自1969年以来撰写的第一集完整剧集。你知道，《鸡侠》年纪大了。而且似乎没有人比他的创作者更清楚这一点。
And now, another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crimefighter the world has ever known.
现在，世界上最奇幻的打击犯罪者生命中又一激动人心的篇章。
Bock bock bock bock!
咯咯咯咯！
Chickenman!
鸡侠！
He's everywhere, he's everywhere!
他无处不在，他无处不在！
["BOCK" ALARM NOISE]
["咯咯"警报声]
Tuesday morning, 9:30 AM. The Chicken Alarm in my Chicken Cave goes off 30 minutes late, which makes me late for my annual physical at my doctor, DuPont Chopper. I didn't want to be late, since it was my first in 30 years. 9:50 AM. I get a flat as I pull the Chicken Coupe out of the Chicken Garage. So I take the convenient number 32 bus, which drops me off only 14 blocks from the doctor's office.
周二上午9:30。我鸡窝里的鸡警报晚了30分钟响起，这让我去杜邦·乔普医生的年度体检迟到了。我不想迟到，因为这是我30年来第一次体检。上午9:50，当我把“鸡车”开出车库时，车胎爆了。所以我乘坐了方便的32路公交车，它把我放在离医生办公室只有14个街区远的地方。
You're late, you're late for a very important date.
你迟到了，你错过了一个非常重要的约会。
--says the doctor. And I say, "I know. I'm sorry. All the air went out of my whatchmacallit."
——医生说。我说：“我知道。我很抱歉。我的那个什么什么东西全没气了。”
Well, that happens to all of us. Age.
嗯，这种事谁都会发生。年龄到了。
11 AM. After several tests and poking and prodding--
上午11点。经过一系列的检查、戳碰和按压——
Well, your cholesterol is a little high. The pain in your toes is arthritis. And I think you have the beginning of a nice hernia.
嗯，你的胆固醇有点高。脚趾的疼痛是关节炎。我想你可能有疝气的早期迹象。
Cholesterol high? I had no idea.
胆固醇高？我根本不知道。
Well, technically, it's not high, because one, it is in your mind. And two, it is your bad cholesterol that's bad. Your good cholesterol is not good. But in time, your bad cholesterol will be good, and your good cholesterol will be bad. And that's not good.
嗯，严格来说并不高，因为第一，它存在于你的大脑里。第二，对你不好的是坏胆固醇。你的好胆固醇其实不好。但过段时间，你的坏胆固醇会变好，而你的好胆固醇会变坏。那可不好。
Anything else?
还有别的事吗？
Yes, you're ugly.
是的，你长得很丑。
That's my Chicken Mask. The beak and, you know, the feathers.
那是我的鸡面具。那个喙，还有，你知道的，那些羽毛。
Uh-huh. Well, don't look at small children or animals. Anyway, that's the health story. But I don't think you have to alter your lifestyle, unless you are a crimefighting superhero of some kind.
嗯。好吧，别看小孩或动物。不管怎样，体检报告就是这样。但我不认为你需要改变生活方式，除非你是个打击犯罪的超级英雄之类的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Want to buy one of my tapes?
想买我的一盘磁带吗？
12:00 noon. I return to the Chicken Cave. And there, in the chicken mirror-- augh!-- I see something horrible. No, not my ugly face, my own mortality. I ask myself why it never stared me in the face before. After all, I've been fighting crime and/or evil for over 30 years, pursuing it down streets and allies and sewers and other picturesque places. And my mortality never came up even once.
中午12:00。我回到鸡窝。在那里，从鸡镜里——啊！——我看到了可怕的东西。不，不是我那张丑脸，而是我自己的死亡临近。我问自己为什么以前从未直面过它。毕竟，我打击犯罪和/或邪恶已经超过30年了，在街道、小巷、下水道和其他风景如画的地方追踪它。而我的死亡从未被提起过一次。
1:40 PM. I go see the police commissioner and share with him the doctor's diagnosis. After all, he is my closest friend. And if I can't tell him the bad news, who can I tell? So I give him a new coloring book I bought for him and tell him my sad news. And he says--
下午1:40。我去找警察局长，和他分享医生的诊断。毕竟，他是我最亲密的朋友。如果我不能告诉他坏消息，我还能告诉谁？所以我送给他一本我买的新涂色书，告诉他我的坏消息。他说——
Ha, ha. This looks like a real neat coloring book.
哈，哈。这看起来真是一本好玩的涂色书。
So what do you think commissioner?
那你怎么看，局长？
About what?
关于什么？
What I just shared with you.
我刚才和你分享的事。
Oh. It's a real neat coloring book.
噢。这是一本真好玩的涂色书。
About the diagnosis and the need to alter my lifestyle.
关于那个诊断，以及我需要改变生活方式这件事。
Oh. Well, that would mean that you'd have to-- and of course one can't even be sure that that, you know. So anyway, that's how I see it.
噢。嗯，这意味着你得要……当然，谁也不能确定那个，你知道的。所以，总之，我就是这么看的。
OK. Thanks, commissioner.
好的。谢谢你，局长。
Anytime, winged warrior. After all, what are friends for? And may I ask you a question?
随时欢迎，带翼的战士。毕竟，朋友是干什么用的呢？我可以问你个问题吗？
OK.
可以。
If I make the sky blue in this picture and the mountains brown, do you think the rocks should be chartreuse?
如果我把这幅画里的天空涂成蓝色，山涂成褐色，你觉得岩石应该涂成黄绿色吗？
Perfect.
完美。
4:00 PM. I go to the local office of the Grace Hill Ferguson Employment Agency and Screen Door Company.
下午4:00。我去了当地的“恩典山弗格森职业介绍所和纱门公司”。
OK, when you say something more sed-ren-tarry, what do you mean?
好的，当你提到想要一些比较“静-坐-的”工作时，你是什么意思？
Sedentary. You know, things where I can seden-- sit.
静坐的。你知道，就是那种我可以“静”……坐下的工作。
Oh, OK. What kind of previous work experience do you have?
噢，好的。你以前有什么工作经验？
Basically fighting crime and/or evil.
基本上就是打击犯罪和/或邪恶。
And what special equipment, office or otherwise, are you experienced in using?
那你有什么专业设备，办公或其他方面的操作经验吗？
Geshtukna ray gun.
盖什图卡纳射线枪。
Could you spell that?
能拼一下那个词吗？
G-E-S-H-T-U-K-A-N-A. And I also worked a Chicken Dissolver and a Chicken Modulator and a can opener.
G-E-S-H-T-U-K-A-N-A。我还操作过鸡溶剂、鸡调制器，还有开罐器。
--T-U-K--
——T-U-K——
--A-N-A.
——A-N-A。
OK. Do you know Windows 95?
好的。你会用Windows 95吗？
Look, what light job openings are on your list there? Just look.
听着，你们清单上有什么轻松的职位空缺吗？去看看。
Heavy cable puller, refrigerator and piano mover, cement hailer--
重型电缆牵引工、冰箱和钢琴搬运工、水泥搬运工——
Hauler.
是搬运工（Hauler）。
OK. Big tree planter! Circus tent--
好的。大型植树工！马戏团帐篷——
Miss?
小姐？
What?
什么？
Not holler. Those are all active and heavy things. Anything light I could do?
别说是搬运工了。那都是些繁重费力的活。我能做点轻松的吗？
Yes, a negligee model in a delicatessen.
可以，熟食店里的内衣模特。
I don't--
我不——
Oh, well scratch that, then. Requires previous experience. Oh, here's something really perfect.
好吧，那就算了。这需要相关经验。哦，这儿有个绝佳的职位。
What's that?
是什么？
A napkin-folder in a nouveau Italian-Chinese restaurant specializing in pizza and light salads. Takeout available. Mmm, I'm hungry.
一家新派意大利中餐馆的餐巾折叠员，主打披萨和清淡沙拉。可供外带。嗯，我饿了。
Wednesday morning, 9:30 AM. My Chicken Alarm goes off a half hour late for my geriatric counseling appointment. Tire still flat. So I take the convenient number 18 bus. And that leaves me off only 28 blocks from the counselor's office.
周三早上，9点半。我的“鸡鸣闹钟”晚响了半小时，错过了我的老年心理咨询预约。轮胎还是瘪的。所以我搭了那趟方便的18路公交车。结果它把我放在离咨询室还有28个街区远的地方。
I have one word of advice, Mister. Get out.
先生，我给你一个建议：退出吧。
Excuse me?
抱歉，你说什么？
Get out.
退出吧。
OK, I'm a few minutes late.
好吧，我只是迟到了几分钟。
What? You're 30 years too late. Get out.
什么？你迟到了30年了。退出吧。
Oh, you mean get out, not get out.
哦，你的意思是让我“走开”，而不是“退出”这项工作。
May I suggest a small, desert, superhero retirement community.
那我建议你考虑去一个沙漠里的超级英雄退休社区。
Ooh.
哦。
You play golf?
你会打高尔夫吗？
Not real good, no.
不太会，不行。
Good, you'll fit right in. Neither does Fishwoman or that Flying Newt. I sent them there. They love it.
太好了，你很适合那里。鱼女和那个飞天蝾螈也不会打。我把他们送去了那儿。他们很喜欢。
Fishwoman?
鱼女？
Yeah. Little scaly, nice personality.
对，身上有点鳞片，但性格不错。
OK.
好吧。
Want to buy one of my tapes?
想买一盘我的磁带吗？
2:00 AM, next morning. I can't sleep, and I sip warm milk in the Chicken Cave. What to do? I'm on the horns of a dilemma. Heavy concrete hauler? Fold napkins in nouveau Italian-Chinese restaurant specializing in pizza and light salads? Or challenge the fates?
第二天凌晨2点。我睡不着，在“鸡舍”里啜饮着热牛奶。该怎么办呢？我陷入了两难的境地。去开沉重的混凝土搅拌车？去新派意大利中餐馆折餐巾？还是挑战命运？
8:00 AM. I stand on the roof of Midland City's tallest skyscraper, four dizzy stories high. I hurl a challenge to the fates. This is the winged warrior, fates. I shall go on fighting crime and/or evil. I don't care that my bad cholesterol is bad, that--
早上8点。我站在米德兰市最高摩天大楼的屋顶上，足有四层楼高，让人眩晕。我向命运发出挑战。命运啊，我是带翼的战士。我将继续打击犯罪和/或邪恶。我不在乎我的坏胆固醇指标很高，我也不在乎——
Suddenly, a black cloud forms swiftly in the sky, and I hear--
突然，天空中迅速形成了一朵乌云，我听到——
OK, do what you want. We'll try to be there for you. But watch the fatty foods, the cookies, the ice cream, and good luck to you.
好吧，随你便吧。我们会尽量支持你的。但要少吃高脂肪食物、饼干和冰淇淋，祝你好运。
Who is that?
是谁在那说话？
One of the fates.
命运之一。
Which one?
哪一个？
Frank. Phyllis, Fran and Fred are in Las Vegas. God bless them, they should only win and be well.
弗兰克。菲利斯、弗兰和弗雷德都在拉斯维加斯。上帝保佑他们，愿他们赢钱并一切安好。
OK. Well, fine. I'll just carry on, then.
好吧。行，那我还是继续我的工作吧。
OK. Listen, could you change that mask you're wearing now? It's very ugly and could scare kids and small animals. Thank you very much.
好的。听着，你能换掉你现在戴的那个面具吗？它太丑了，会吓坏孩子和小动物的。非常感谢。
Right.
好的。
And at that moment, I knew fate was blind, and I, the famous fowl, would have the last laugh. For you see, I wasn't wearing a mask.
那一刻，我知道命运是盲目的，而我，这只著名的“鸡”，将会笑到最后。因为你看，我根本没戴面具。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, what has the winged warrior gotten himself into here? Can he actually stop time by challenging the fates? And is it Frank Fate he's talking to or Georgie Jessel? And another thing, doesn't that nouveau Italian-Chinese restaurant sound super-trendy? Be listening tomorrow for another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crimefighter the world has ever known.
那么，这位带翼的战士究竟陷入了什么境地？他真的能通过挑战命运来暂停时间吗？他是在和命运之神弗兰克说话，还是在和乔治·杰塞尔说话？另外，那家新派意大利中餐馆听起来是不是超时尚？明天请继续收听关于这位世上最棒的打击犯罪英雄的精彩剧集。
Bock bock bock bock!
咯咯咯咯！
Chickenman.
鸡人。
He's everywhere, he's everywhere!
他无处不在，他无处不在！
Well, "Chickenman Challenges a Fate Named Frank" was recorded at Dick Orkin's radio ranch in Hollywood, California. Along with Dick Orkin, the cast included Charlie Brill, Allison Anne Martin, Miriam Flynn, and Jim Gallant. Engineers Elizabeth Lane and James Burns. Written by Dick Orkin and Christine Coyle. Ms. Flynn's hairstyle by Mr. Bunny.
刚才那集《鸡人挑战命运之神弗兰克》是在好莱坞迪克·奥金的无线电牧场录制的。除了迪克·奥金，演员还包括查理·布里尔、艾莉森·安妮·马丁、米里亚姆·弗林和吉姆·加兰特。工程师是伊丽莎白·莱恩和詹姆斯·伯恩斯。由迪克·奥金和克里斯汀·科伊尔编写。弗林女士的发型由邦尼先生设计。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助名单]
The show is produced by Dolores Wilber, Nancy Updike, Peter Clowney, Alix Spiegel and myself. Contributing editors Margi Rochlin, Paul Tough, and Jack Hitt. Many songs in tonight's program were provided by Mr. Steve Cushing and the Blues Before Sunrise Radio Network. Our program comes to you from WBEZ Chicago. Our address, 848 East Grand Avenue, Navy Pier, Chicago, 60611. Our email address, oh why don't you write us, [email protected] . That's [email protected] .
本节目由多洛莉丝·威尔伯、南希·厄普代克、彼得·克劳尼、艾利克斯·斯皮格尔和我共同制作。特约编辑：玛吉·罗克林、保罗·塔夫和杰克·希特。今晚节目中的许多歌曲由史蒂夫·库欣和“日出前的蓝调”广播网提供。我们的节目来自芝加哥WBEZ电台。我们的地址是芝加哥海军码头大格兰德大道848号，邮编60611。我们的电子邮箱地址是[email protected]，为什么不给我们写信呢？那是[email protected]。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
And finally, thanks to the Mattoon family, Ashley, Lynn, Duki, Yona Lu, and of course, Danielle.
最后，感谢马通一家，阿什利、琳恩、杜基、尤娜·卢，当然还有丹妮尔。
I just want a real person who's like Duki, probably. I want to go marry some guy who's like Duki.
我只是想要一个像杜基那样真实的人，可能吧。我想嫁给一个像杜基那样的男人。
And how's that search going?
那你的寻觅进展如何了？
Not well.
不太顺利。
I'm Ira Glass. See you next week, same chicken time, same chicken channel. Same brave little radio station.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周见，同样的鸡时间，同样的鸡频道。同样的勇敢小电台。
Ira?
艾拉？
Hmm?
嗯？
Don't make me sound like an idiot, OK?
别把我剪辑得像个傻瓜，好吗？
Done.
没问题。